foreign
creatures can live in the smallest
corners of your home and the darkest
places you don't dare visit well not
anymore because today we're killing
every single snake on earth
how would this snake hunt begin
would we have to invent a bio weapon to
finish the job
and why would things get medieval
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we killed all snakes
the time for war has come
Humanity has decided that the snake's
reign of terror on our planet is over
but what are we up against
well first don't assume these animals
will be easy to take down
these cannibalistic carnivores may not
have ears but can sense sound waves
through their skin to know what's around
them don't think their poor eyesight
will help you either while they can't
perceive colors and have fuzzy Vision
some can see heat sources as if they
were wearing infrared goggles
see that flickering tongue it can pick
up odor particles from the air
the muscles in that jaw can open wide
and devour prey larger than them
that could be your fate if you fail
but if you did succeed on your mission
how could this bring back the most
horrible disease ever
there are about 3 400 recorded species
of snakes slithering around Earth
according to the World Health
Organization snake bites kill over 100
000 people every year
so how are you going to take those
numbers down to zero well to start
you'll need to visit the warmer regions
of the planet
you'll also have to search trees Fields
And even underground spaces like sewers
remember these are literally
cold-blooded killers
snakes need a place that allows them to
hunt and regulate their body temperature
so maybe you could freeze them out
yeah well they're more resilient than
you might think
Burmese pythons are an invasive species
that have been found in the Florida
Wilds since the 1980s
after a record cold snap in 2010 these
Predators adapted to the climate and
started breeding like crazy
so the cold air might not work
maybe you could create a bio weapon
instead
snake fungal disease has already been
spreading globally it causes painful
lesions on a snake's skin which can lead
to death
some snakes can shed their skin to get
rid of it but others aren't so lucky
and once it infects one snake it can
easily spread to others nearby
so if humans could distribute this
fungus to every snake on the planet we
could wipe them all out quickly
okay so now these reptilian menaces are
gone for good but did you just Doom the
planet
without snakes eating them rodents birds
and amphibians like frogs would rise in
numbers
and while these animals might be happy
for the moment that feeling would be
short-lived
that's because they would all be
competing for the same resources to feed
eventually creating a scarcity of food
for all of them
and if you're a farmer you'd have to
deal with an increased rodent population
on your land you'd have to use more
pesticides to fight for your crops and
as a consumer you'd have to pay more
money for your groceries because the
same food would now cost more to produce
but the biggest price you'll pay won't
be at the register all the rodents
scurrying around could spread diseases
across the globe you might even see a
Resurgence of the bubonic plague
yeah the plague could come back and in a
big way
and snakes weren't even on the top of
the food chain either
boars mongooses and birds of prey like
owls and Eagles depend on snakes for
their diet if you killed every snake
many of these species would decline in
numbers some might even become extinct
not to mention humans rely on snake
venom for medicinal purposes potential
treatments for diabetes and cancer have
been derived from it with no further
access to snake venom we could endanger
even more human life
like all things in nature snakes have
their place among us and that place is
not near me so keep your distance
but is every animal the same
what if we killed all ticks instead
well keep watching because that's a
story
for another
what if